Adam Schefter from the mothership set to
join us you can see Adam year round on
ESPN's TV and radio shows and playing a
significant role in ESPN's coverage of
the NFL Draft also hear more Adam on the
Adam Schefter podcast available in the
ESPN app at ESPN pods Center and via the
Apple iTunes Store did you think of any
other name for your podcast than the
Adam Schefter podcast Adam podcast but I
decide to go with the Adam Schefter
podcast instead then yeah probably more
people listening by going with Adam
Schecter I don't blame you we're two
weeks away from the draft do you think
the Browns know who they're taking I
think they have a very good idea now in
talking to them if the owners meetings
two weeks ago I know their big thing
then was we want to go back in the lab
they called the lab go back in the lab
study film of these guys go over the
process now Hugh Jackson said at the
meetings that he thought the team might
not decide until the day of the draft
through they're taking which sounds a
little late to me but it sees you an
idea of what these teams go through and
even the Giants they gentleman was
saying that there's nobody that could
really know who they're taking because
you're still going through all the
interviews you're still bringing guys
and you're still accumulating more
medical information things change I mean
where everybody was projecting Anna
Rodgers to be the number one overall
pick it's all about the week before the
draft and then somehow something changed
to her Alex Smith leapfrogged him and
Anna Rodgers began a slide that led him
to Green Bay at number 24 everyone
thought he was going on board so these
things are fluid then and you could
think that a certain players going at a
certain spot only to see that scenario
change a week or two later and we've got
13 days to the NFL Draft
I think the Browns have a pretty good
idea about what direction they're going
to go what does that just lock them into
anything right now if you were gonna bet
like a week's pay of mike Greenberg
salary would you say you know who that
quarterback is
I would be unload a bit that much money
right now Dan because I don't know what
the answer is
you know come last year I was told that
Josh our you could put it down will be
the number one overall pick in the draft
all right a couple of different GM's
a year out and so I always thought Josh
I will be the number one guy then there
was a big stand Arnold conversation that
he would go number one and now we're
sort of back to Josh out on the game but
you hear about Donald so the only thing
I could tell you unequivocally
I would be able to bear a sliver of
greeny salary that the normal pick is
unequivocally going to be a quarterback
no doubt that like there was some
ridiculous sacrum Barkley conversation
for some time that he was never going
number one okay it's gonna be a
quarterback and I don't know whether
it's gonna be Donald or Alan or even
Mayfield okay so if if a quarterback is
gonna be taking is gonna be one of those
three guys in your opinion the guess the
key to the first-round draft is which
team well I didn't enjoy choo-choo or
the little key now that that seems to be
the team that everybody seems to be
asking about when you're talking to them
what are the Giants doing because people
don't know whether they're going
quarterback or child or even Barkley and
we know the Jets are going quarterback
at three so what the Browns are going to
be a 1 the Jets are going Cuban at 3 and
then we got the Browns back up again we
don't know whether the Giants are gonna
go for one of these blue chip positional
players or whether they're going to try
to secure that quarterback position and
and again I think they gentleman's been
tough to predict if you look at his
record under we've seen some running
backs go there we've seen some interior
lineman go there so ok I'm just telling
you and talking to teams they all seem
to be confounded by what the Giants are
doing he's Adam Schefter from the
mothership part of the draft coverage
joining a Stan Patrick show what do we
not know about the Colin Kaepernick
situation with the Seahawks yes he was
booked for
look out about two weeks ago and that
workout was supposed to occur on Monday
and I'm Tuesday by the way he was
scheduled and did give his depositions
to the league attorneys in that
grievance case regarding the collusion
against him so that would be quite a
Monday and Tuesday working out for
Seattle Monday meeting with NFL
attorneys on Tuesday now only one of
those two events occurred so the
Seahawks booked them for this trip and
then as it was told to me there was a
last-minute stipulation that's the
phrase that was used to mean last-minute
stipulation they wanted to know whether
he could commit to not standing or not
kneeling for the answer next year and
he/she didn't give them this he wouldn't
say you want to talk about it but they
wanted an assurance that he wouldn't be
kneeling which he was unwilling to give
now that doesn't mean he's going to be
kneeling or not kneeling or whatever
would be if you were given the chance to
play in the NFL this season but he
wasn't ready to give them an answer at
that point in time he was happy to talk
about it and the Seahawks
felt like they needed a more absolute
concrete answer before they brought him
in and so depending on who you talk to
you the visit was either postponed or
cancelled now the Seahawks say that
they're still considering him and still
could bring him back in and still could
walk them out sign up not just since
I've got some other people but we'll see
if that's right and of course overnight
this young sign another quarterback
Stephen Morris he's bounced around the
league I don't think that that
completely precludes them going after
Colin Kaepernick you're not saying to
yourself boy we shot a Stephen moss
we're set at the back of quarterback
position right now we don't have to
bring in anybody else okay I just think
that they're getting ready to start the
offseason workout programs you won't
have another quarterback around they had
to cut trevone Boykin during the owners
meetings because the domestic violence
allegations there and so they went ahead
and signed him but do you think about
this Dan since Colin Kaepernick opted
out of the 49ers contract and obviously
he became a extreme public figure that
he did over his stances regarding me
anthem he does not have a single workout
for a team yeah
single workouts who plays in the NFL
next between Manziel and Kaepernick it's
a great question I would I would guess
Johnny Manziel is the next one to get
the opportunity but I could totally be
wrong there like for all we know the
Seahawks are gonna call next week and
say we've reconsidered this a would go
with whatever you want to do let's talk
about this agreement that would be great
to see you know i'd like to see Colin
get a chance to come in and play
quarterback in the league again and I
hope I'm wrong there but my guess would
be Manziel just a guess but we'll see if
that works out Dez Bryant situation as
Dez Bryant a cowboy after today I would
guess not that'd be my guess going in I
know other people have said that they
expect them back I am NOT as sure about
that at all I think that the signs have
been there all along this is a Cowboys
team that inquired about Sammy Watkins
that did sign Allen Hurns and Donte
Thompson that has brought in multiple
wide receivers to their training complex
to visit for the draft that has
basically been in need of more salary
cap space to go pay Zack Martin and
DeMarcus Lawrence and I just think that
we all said and done I think that this
is not going to work out the way that
des would like now again you could sit
down with Jerry in there and maybe maybe
Jerry offers in the pay cut maybe he
doesn't but these things can take
strange turns see to me des barn is
limited it's April 13th he had been
released on march 13th his market would
be better and stronger you know he
doesn't have a spot in Oakland anymore
the Raiders sign short he knows he
doesn't have a spot in Baltimore anymore
the Ravens signed John Brown and Michael
Crabtree it isn't a spot in Cleveland
anymore they signed Jarvis Landry so
some of these teams that needed wide
receivers like the bear Swensen Allen
Robinson III guess one of them could
always make space for Dez Bryant yeah
the majority of them have committed
their cap dollars to other wide
receivers so we put you in a tough spot
so Joey comes in with a
got it might be in this planet's best
interest to take it but I also think
it's distinctly possible that Jerry
Jones doesn't even do that and Jerry
just makes the unilateral decision Dez
we're moving on I mean that could happen
too and we're not surprised me so again
I don't know how that meetings gonna
work out damn but I think those are the
options on the table you know the one
thing we do know is Dez Bryant is not
returning to Dallas Cowboys on the 12
and a half million dollar contract as it
currently is constituted Adam thanks for
joining us and we'll check in with you
soon thanks for your time that's Adam
Schefter from the mothership there for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show at
[Music]